what do we had time perfect again
unhelpful questions were Bobby and
kalila we should do a better job at the
unhelpful advice because we've been
slacking I'm not I do 100% of the
thoughtful advice I want to be
thoughtful could you go ahead dude
single [ __ ] or threesome dear Bobby I'm
wait wait dear Bobby I'm finally getting
a place of my own I'm about to fill
fulfill my childhood dream of getting
[ __ ] dot dot dot a cat I really would
like a pair of kitties but I'm hesitant
as I would be a first-time owner how
much better is it owning multiple cats
opposed to just one thanks June from
Google and PS your bit as tank and Matty
be still makes me piss my pants ok stop
thank you and I want to see this and
this is a fact that you need to Breezy
too because when I was in San Jose
improv or the manager of hooman he is
the manager Club Group one by one the
best managers in comedy history I love
this guy nicest guy in the world um he
got one cat the cat was lonely he got to
life was better my friend Billy Bonnell
- he has two cats I mean we have three
but the third one was an accident
ooh oh yeah this yeah mojo was like a
call out of nowhere and you know me and
from a fire station we had to take it
yeah and we nursed it back to life and
that was a gift from God my point though
is is that you need to because you leave
that [ __ ] thing's gonna be in the
house alone
and can't you know you can find is
brothers or sisters or like a relate a
related relationship usually keep them
in the same actual kennel - if they're
in the same litter and stuff you can go
to kennel and get like a brother and
sister or two broad whatever right do it
that's the way to do it you know I mean
and now you guys did first of whatever
was with Gunnar we picked it up and he
had a brother and they were in the same
kennel but some [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
mean adopted or Dobby his first one yeah
so we could only get gunner and they you
know they did was when we picked up
gunner he go we're gonna say goodbye
Gunners gonna say goodbye to his brother
and his brother and gunner started
crying like crazy scream screaming
because they were being separated and
separated did it in front of us really
yeah like dude that [ __ ] when we're not
here the goodbyes
yeah [ __ ] you know man but they didn't
you know I mean but to this person it's
very important to get to get to cats
yeah Oh cats are the best they really
are my life you agree to kay yeah
because when we first had Ming Bobby can
tell you our first cat was alone for the
first year of her life
and she was a lonely girl like she with
it took her forever to get out of her
feral State because she didn't have any
other pets around her so when we would
Bobby would go in a road or if we were
both gone
you know the he were she she was
miserable alone and then she her
personality completely changed and she's
complete a thousand times more lovable
now now that she has the two boys
whether I didn't know anything about
cats and I remember dating kalila and
I'm like I'll take Ming to my house see
what happens and for 24 hours I'm I left
water and food in here but I just left
it in here for 24 hours he didn't know
in this room yeah
and this one locked it and I walked in
here like 24 hours later and he she's on
that table just shaking by herself yeah
oh is that why she's so skinny well she
was trauma no it was me grew up off the
street you grew up on the street right
they left her that thing alone for three
month I know when we first got Ming was
when Bobby and I first started dating
and I was in and out a lot and my
roommate was in and out a lot too but we
she was with a dog she was actually
raised with a dog but when she moved in
with Bobby and I she had no dog anymore
it was just her by herself I am NOT a
bad pet owner how dare you anyway get to
is there any other ones yeah one more
hey guys just listening to the earlier
episode where you talk about your trip
to the Philippines when kalila had a
heart episode and was wondering if Bobby
would ever go back and visit the
Philippines again after that experience
Oh John was a traumatic oh man oh yeah
you would go back and we're gonna go
back next January when are
you know hopefully we're not what he
calls George it'll be fun you want to
call yeah and we'll tape stuff maybe
we'll do a short film we'll do something
you don't think it'd be traumatic for
you at all no no I loved it there man I
mean if you saw the two videos that I
posted in the first two days I was there
the first day I did a I did a little
karate thing on by a pool and then I did
a dance thing in the lobby it was so
much fun it was a great place it's
impossible not to have fun in the
Philippines the Philippines is just
primed for a good time yes so fun you
know and the [ __ ] river is there only a
couple [ __ ] rivers I saw it's a couple
just a couple yeah I mean just two
really big [ __ ] rivers mm-hmm well just
just a river flowing with [ __ ] that was
Tyler's town yeah kiss plug your dates
oh [ __ ] Bobby show say something while I
look for his dates
[Music]